à propos des attentats du 11 septembre
un livre récemment sorti en france
affirme que le pentagone n'a pas été
détruit par un avion suicide mais par
une explosion mars 2002 six mois
seulement après les attentats du 11
septembre les premières théories du
complot apparaissent des thèses alimenté
sur internet c'est le début du
complotisme 2.0 rudy reichstadt s'en
souvient il est aujourd'hui directeur de
l'observatoire du conspirationnisme en
fait le long septembre 2001 c'est une
date symbolique qui marque le
basculement dans un autre monde celui la
fois du terrorisme mondialisé et celui
des théories du complot mondialisée
également qui va s'accélérer évidemment
avec internet les thèses complotistes
autour du 11 septembre se popularise sur
internet mais aussi au travers de ce
livre en 2002 l'auteur thierry meyssan
en pleine promo enchaînait les plateaux
télé vous êtes vous va jamais retrouver
l'épave de l'avion en fait pour là
j'avais vu on n'a jamais trouvé le
moindre morceau de cet avion à
l'exception des boîtes noires mon a
exhibé avec beaucoup de retard et puis
on aurait retrouvé d'après le pentagone
un phare de l'avion qu'on n'a jamais
montré maintenant dit qu'on l'a retrouvé
six colons c'est possible d'avoir ça sur
le service public c'est que ce type est
sérieux c'est que on a là quelqu'un qui
a fait une enquête c mais l'avion qui a
décollé il est où c'est un avion qui a
décollé à un moment quand un avion qui a
décollé il y avait des passagers à
l'intérieur
cet avion on en a perdu toute trace à
500 km de washington au dessus de l'ohio
ouais y'a aucune nouvelle depuis est
certainement le gouvenement américain
aurait des révélations à faire aux
familles de ses victimes on s'apercevra
seulement après que en fait banquette il
n'a même pas posé les pieds aux
etats-unis thierry meyssan il est resté
derrière son écran d'ordinateur ça qui
est fascinant et s'appuie sur des
sources qui sont des sources
complotistes m
pourtant le livre de thierry meyssan
traduit en 28 langues second à l'époque
à plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'exemplaires même succès pour ces trois
américains en 2005 leur film loose
change remettait en question la version
officielle des attentats et il fascinait
les internautes c'est un film qui va
faire basculer c'est vrai beaucoup de
gens dans dans conspiration vision
septembre ça va être un instrument
puissant de séduction pour le
complotisme et l'opération séduction a
aussi fonctionné sur plusieurs
personnalités françaises comme jean
marie bigard en 2008 on est absolument
sûr et certain maintenant que les deux
avions celui qui s'est écrasé suivant la
forêt par ailleurs n'existe pas y ait
jamais eu d'avion c'est des avions
volent encore c'est un mensonge
absolument énorme quoi jean marie bigard
reviendra sur ses propos
mais 20 ans après les faits les thèses
complotistes sur les attentats du
11-septembre résiste en 2019 pour 17 %
des françaises interrogées le
gouvernement américain a été impliqué
dans ces attentats
[Musique]